[Music]
terrifying Psychopaths ancient demons
Frankenstein let's explore some of the
best horror films ever made from horror
classics to recent masterpieces these
films earned perfect Rotten Tomatoes
scores and you need to know why
Hans Becker stalks the streets of Berlin
only to a casual passerby it might not
look like stalking beckert is physically
unassuming he's a wide-eyed don't be
nobody who's more easily imagined behind
a typewriter than the handle of a knife
and yet says berliners are about to
learn Hans Beckett is a monster a Serial
murderer compelled to kill children
soon beckert's crimes cast a fearful
Shadow over the city the authorities
cracked down utilizing every forensic
tool at their disposal meanwhile the
criminal underbelly begins to assemble
its own Manhunt so they can resume their
activities and bothered by the
heightened police presence it would be a
mistake to dismiss M for its age
released in 1931 Fritz Lang's masterful
procedural Terror trip has lost none of
its staying power M occupies the fuzzy
midsection of the Venn diagram between
the horror and Thriller genres rubbing
bloodied shoulders with the likes of
Manhunter seven and a deep red Lang's
vision of Berlin is a sparse and Barren
Place suffocated in Shadow lawmurn and
criminals are indistinguishable forces
cruel Twisted men prone to violence
fraying at the seams and overwhelmed by
a desire to re-establish control despite
his minimal Screen Time Peter Laurie's
beckerd conjures both our propulsion and
understanding he's monstrous yes Birds
tower has violent compulsions different
from those of the berliners itching to
spill his blood
arguably m stands for Masterpiece after
all Lang's film boasted an arguably
perfect score on Rotten Tomatoes with
the likes of Roger Ebert hailing the
film a portrait of a disease Society
it's a wonder it escaped the attention
of the Nazi sensors
the gargantuan Gothic pillar of the
classical Hollywood era James Wales
Frankenstein adapts Mary Shelley's 1818
novel of the same name with tremendous
style Grace and pathos fueled by a
Promethean desire to play God Dr Henry
Frankenstein says about fashioning an
Abomination out of Rotting Flesh
you he's alive
directed by the legendary James whale
this Monumental classic refuses to show
its age running circles around its
Universal monster appears that later
emerged and felt altogether lifeless by
comparison it is impossible to praise
Frankenstein without paying homage to
Boris karlov's performance without
uttering a word Karloff cements his
immortality on the Silver Screen as a
physical force to be reckoned with who's
capable of conjuring pity out of wounded
glances and shaking Palms Frankenstein
is a tragic tale of arrogance and
existential meddling and its perfect
Rotten Tomatoes score is further
Testament to a story that continues to
move and shock in the 21st century
it's no small miracle that Jaguar
cargo's legendary hard to watch angst
currently enjoys a 100 rating on Rotten
Tomatoes a devoted illustration of the
brutality perpetuated by real-life
Psychopaths angst follows an unnamed
serial killer after he is released from
prison as soon as the gates closed
behind him the thoroughly
unrehabilitated killer immediately
scampers off into the world to commit
the perfect murder
this was always part of the plan now
it's just a question of finding a
suitable victim after several false
starts and missed opportunities the
killer soon hits a madman's jackpots a
secluded estate surrounded by thick
Woods when the inhabitants an elderly
woman her daughter and handicapped son
return home the killer wastes no time
unleashing its perverse desires on the
unsuspecting family angst is one of
those films you can't really recommend
him good conscience to anyone but it is
undoubtedly one of the greatest horror
films ever committed to Celluloid the
killer monologues throughout the film's
run time detailing his sadism and
decision making with a nerving ease
forcing its audience into unbearably
close proximity to its subjects even the
cinematography lurches and floats with
disembodied queasiness and curiosity
charged with a primal and distressingly
clumsy violence few films can genuinely
claim to be this viscerally
uncomfortable to sit through
an outstanding feature film debut from
British director Remy weeks his house
follows bold and real a couple who
arrive in the United Kingdom after
fleeing South Sudan as a condition of
their Asylum bowl and real must abide by
the strict rules that govern their
day-to-day lives and must live in a
signed housing it's a crumbling
tenement's house in a racist
neighborhood but after dealing with so
many hardships having a roof over their
heads means the world to them while bold
tries to assimilate into British culture
real can't shape the feeling that
something dark has followed them across
the ocean still grieving the loss of
their daughter who did not survive the
journey the couple soon begins to feel
the presence of something dark and angry
lurking within the walls of the house
they've been ordered to live in his
house is a harrowing and powerfully
realized tale of survivor's guilt and
the ghosts of the past exposes the real
horrors of a dehumanizing immigration
system while Conjuring actually
disturbing Supernatural Spooks an
emotional and genuinely terrifying
modern take on the haunted house formula
this film recalls the nightmarish stream
logic of Lucio Fouche while carving out
of space all its own sporting a perfect
critical consensus from Rotten Tomatoes
his house balances its disarming
intelligence with a genuinely unsettling
imagery that puts most modern
Supernatural fear to shame as Tim
Greer's son of screamed daily after
these sums up the film has much to say
about grief guilt assimilation and the
ongoing Refugee crisis and on top of
that it's also a Nifty nerve jungler in
the end his house has proof that horror
films can do it all
this is our home
if you haven't had the joy of watching
one because of the Dead just yet heed
this warning it is best if possible to
go into it blind no spoilers here but
proceed at your own risk part of the
undeniable charm of shinachiro weddings
2017 Japanese horror film is in its
Revelations it has a cunning way of
lulling you into thinking you're in for
yet another low budget found footage
flick before revealing that it's
something else entirely to say much more
would be to give away the mid-film rug
pull but if you're finding yourself
rolling your eyes during the film's
First Act push on there are bloody
Delights awaiting you on the other side
to call it a slow burn doesn't really do
it justice one because of the Dead is
more akin to a long and winding standard
routine sitting pretty with a perfect
Rotten Tomato score as a time of
publishing one cut of the dead has been
unanimously praised for a cheeky mix of
gleeful Gore and intelligent meta
commentary as Los Angeles Times but said
the film is a masterclass and endless
narrative inventiveness and an Ode to
the resourceful and collaborative spirit
threads of Hands-On filmmaking part of
that collaboration comes from you the
audience and your willingness to give
yourself over to wedders and furling
Russian doll as the title boldly
proclaims much of its action takes place
in a genuine single take free from Cuts
but Bountiful in bites screams and
foregone limbs few horror films manage
to secure a Flawless Rotten Tomatoes
score
look the early days of quarantine made
all of us do wild things but not to
victim blame here holding a virtual Zoom
Seance is just asking for trouble host
follows six Pals who have the right idea
to hire a medium to help them
communicate with the dead over the
Internet what begins as an awkward
filler for their weekly Zoom hang soon
descends into something far more
Sinister the group begins to notice
unexplainable phenomena and realize that
their cheeky social events might have
Unleashed a malevolent Spirit a document
of both The Uncanny digital state of
being that defines modern day quarantine
and the increasing popularity of the
screen life genre hosts earns unanimous
Praise on Rotten Tomatoes as Jenna
stober writes for polygon the film is
deeply clever playing got familiar
aspects of video call technology and not
at all skimping on the stunts Mary Beth
McAndrews a film cred also sums up the
film's appeal nicely saying the film
proves how crucial found footage is in
capturing social fears by adapting to
current and world events and the popular
technology that goes with it for the
best viewing results watching your
laptop and you're bad at two in the
morning with the lights off
Aaron is getting old 40 is looming on
the horizon and his Prussian project is
starting to feel like any home drum day
job and hey look midlife crises are a
dime a dozen they're a natural parts of
getting older and staring your own
mortality in the face and for Aaron the
joy of plunging axes and kitchen knives
into unsuspecting jugulars just doesn't
have the same Pizzazz now that gray
hairs have started invading his temples
murdering people just doesn't have the
same genocide choir that it used to and
finding himself going through the
motions Aaron begins to wonder how he
can carry on enter Sarah an aspiring
director in a similar creative slump her
web series encounters isn't doing as
well as she'd hoped and in a last-ditch
effort to save her show Sarah answers
Aaron's Sinister Craigslist ad she shows
up in the middle of nowhere with a
camera and an open mind you gotta keep
the camera on if you want to keep the
magic a tour's tension-filled game of
cat and mouse where it's never quite
clear who is the cats and who is the
mouse creep 2 is a shock talking
follow-up to 2014's creep the blend of
dark humor and found footage horror
tropes to skin crawling effect released
in 2017 many critics including AV clubs
Alex MC Levy claims that the sequel
outshines its predecessor in nearly
every way with Desiree arkovan's
magnetic screen presence throughout the
film dead Central's Jonathan Barker
notes that creep 2 creates a quote White
Knuckle anxiety-inducing tension doctor
of psychology and odd and skeptic Dr
John Holden is on route to London to
co-facilitate a rather peculiar seminar
it's a lecture aimed at exposing devil
worship Witchcraft and occult power as
nothing more than smoke mirrors and
persuasion the central Target of the
Symposium is a ridiculously goateed
Julian Carswell a local cult leader who
appears to have a vice grip on his
followers when Dr Holden arrives in
England he is surprised to learn that
his collaborator Dr Harrington has been
killed in a freak electrical accident
only his whips my on these sinks have
brutalized state of her uncle's corpse
points to a far more violent and perhaps
Supernatural cause while Dr Holden
remains adamant that Carswell is nothing
but a Charming con man the evidence
begins stacking up that he may be the
next to die by unnatural means the film
is directed by the French Master of the
Macabre Jacques toner The Man Behind cat
people and I Walt with a zombie Knight
of the demon bits stubborn rationality
against unhinged beliefs with genuinely
terrifying results while folk horror
wouldn't be properly codified as a
horror sub-genre until the late 1960s or
early 1970s the Rumblings of
occult-based cinematic Spooks are
present in this 1957 Chiller a Chicago
Reader critic Dave care writes in his
1985 review intelligent delicate and
actually frightening tornaris attempting
a rational apprehension of the
irrational examining not so much the
supernatural itself but the insecurities
it Springs from and the uses it may be
put to okay
a renowned Big Game Hunter named Rob is
cheerfully sailing on a luxury yacht but
galing his fellow passengers with
thrilling Tales of his past exploits
then suddenly their vessel smashes into
an Uncharted Reef killing everyone on
board except Bob who miraculously
survives and washes up on the shore of a
seemingly desolate Caribbean island soon
Bob finds himself the guest of The
Eccentric count Zaroff a mysterious
Russian recluse finding that he is not
the only Shipwrecked guest in zarov's
Castle Bob soon learns that his house
Fashions himself something of an
accomplished Hunter only kanzarov dozens
hunt animals his interests lie elsewhere
in more cunning prey humans
here on my Island
I hunt the most dangerous game
set loose into the treacherous jungle
bobbin fellow victim Eve must survive
until sunrise if they want to make us
off the island alive somewhere between
cowering and Tree Trunks and evading
zaroff's hounds Bob begins to sympathize
with the animals he once hunted based on
a 1924 short story by Richard Connell
Irving pitchell and Ernest B sugar sacks
1932 adaptation of the most dangerous
game is truly remarkable it was lauded
by contemporary New York Times critic
modern's Hall as quote a highly
satisfactory melodrama who will also
Reserve special praise for banks seen
stealing performance as it dastily
counts meanwhile modern day Outlets like
Thai Mouse have positively remarked on
the film's status claiming the most
dangerous game is one of the best and
most literate movies from the great Days
of Horror wasting no time with its
Breakneck Pace the most dangerous game
persists nearly a century later but as
morbid Delights
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more Looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell so you don't miss a single one